the corona virus pandemic has really
sort of accelerated and intensified this
anti-china investment agenda the China's
posture these days towards the u.s. is
to show no deference there's a strong
public feeling in America that America
shouldn't have its eggs in the China
basket I don't know that China really
cares that much if it's winning any new
friends through this crisis
so ed how have we got to the point where
the relationship between these two
countries is unraveling so rapidly I'd
like to think of it as a like a divorce
process here you have this couple that
have been together for years that have
got rich together that have become in
the last few years increasingly verbally
abusive towards each other with the hint
of possibly worse yet because of their
wealth and the fact that their assets
are so deeply entangled an actual
divorce is not something their financial
advisors would wish to see the emotional
side of this though is what's really
dominating and I know you James as a
long-term China observer you've seen the
change in trend what we have over here
that's shocking all kinds of trying to
observers is the emergence of these
undiplomatic Chinese diplomats over here
they call them the wolf warrior
diplomats and that that name comes from
Chinese films where special ops soldiers
basically take out Western mercenaries
and some of the things that are becoming
out of these guys mouths is quite
extraordinary one Chinese diplomat jaffa
jolly Jen who's the foreign ministry
spokesman suggested that this virus
could have been brought to China by the
US military also that that old Chinese
phrase from Deng Xiaoping bide your time
hide your light under a bushel that's
clearly not true
you know since Trump was elected on the
basis of China is ravaging raping our
economy as increasingly through the
trade wars in the last few years but
also through rhetoric through this
emotional idea that if the world really
is a zero-sum game and now we have very
prominent to the champions like Tom
cotton the Republican senator talking
about China is the new evil empire and
China being alleged by Trump to
have pretty much deliberately caused to
this pandemic that no have not even 100
trade deals will be worth the innocent
lives lost is something he tweeted the
other day this is this is beyond
emotionally abusive this is very
aggressive language so unhappy
couples tend to agree that they're
unhappy but when it comes to splitting
assets that's when the real disputes
come come into action how complex would
this asset division look one of the
things we have to realize is that the
us-china commercial interaction has
really been the most important
commercial relationship in history the
US companies invested hundreds of
billions of US dollars into China over
the last 40 years in many ways they've
really helped engineer China's economic
rise and in recent years China's
economic rise has been absolutely vital
for the global economy in fact China has
contributed more than just over
one-third of total global GDP growth so
this is an absolutely vital relationship
in terms of the welfare of the global
economy but recently we've just seen
parts of this relationship just fall off
a cliff the part I'd like to highlight
is Chinese investment into the u.s. in
the first quarter of this year we saw it
fall to just 200 million US dollars
that's about 1/10 the level of that we
saw every quarter last year and last
year itself was the lowest year for
Chinese investment into the US since
2009 Chinese companies these days seem
to really fear to go to the US are you
seeing that is that what it feels like
over there there is a strong you know
suspicion guilty till proven again
walking ready chinese FDI of any
description particularly huawei of
course the big china telecoms giant and
I think the corona virus pandemic has
really sort of accelerated and
intensified this anti China investment
agenda there's a strong public feeling
in America trumpian feeling if you like
that America shouldn't have its eggs in
the China basket and then lastly a
federal government of Trump
administration moved to a disinvest
public pension funds or not allow public
pension funds to invest in Chinese asset
if that spreads to the entire financial
relationship then I think we're in to
round two or three of this decoupling
and the division of the assets will be
really quite painful for the US economy
the Chinese economy and everybody else
and learn summers the former US
Treasuries actually used to refer to the
prospect of a financial decoupling as
mutually assured destruction actual
mutually assured destruction and of
course that's what financial advisors of
divorcing couples would say it's crazy
you're going to both end up poorer but I
guess it all boils down to whether they
hate each other more another aspect of
this a really key word is the impact of
this
decoupling on friends and neighbors
which I think we should talk about next
the anti China rhetoric is kind of the
main offshoot of the whole America first
agenda and the America first agenda
isn't just aggressive towards China its
aggressive towards any multilateral body
its aggressive towards any alliance its
skeptical of any alliance it's really
predicated on Trump's view the the world
has been ripping America off for too
long
China being the top of that list but the
hope will help being on it basically so
I think it's alienating allies who would
ordinarily be sharing America's fear of
a rising China the most egregious
example of this has come really during
the corona virus pandemic and that is
with Trump's suspension of funding to
the World Health Organization and then
his threat to dr. T drops the head of
the w-h-o that America would withdraw
within 30 days unless it ceased to be
dependent on China this is exactly the
kind of thing that alienates America's
friends and allies there are myriad of
examples before the pandemic I guess my
question to you is is China picking up
friends and allies at the rate that
America is alienating Perth you know my
feeling is that I don't know that China
really cares that much if it's winning
any new friends through this crisis it
seems to me that China's posture these
days towards the u.s. is to show no
deference as far as China sees it this
crisis is more about the decline of the
West than it is about the rise of China
I think it's showing a new confidence
and new sense of conviction in
international relations and the other
thing is I don't really think that China
is directing its charm offensive mainly
at the West these days anyway I think
China's trauma offensive is being
directed at developing nations as you
well know Edie
China has this huge plan to build
infrastructure in developing countries
all over the world called the belton
Road initiative China's been lending
hundreds of billions of US dollars to
that end and I think it's there that
China wants to build long-term
relationships whether it's succeeding at
that at the moment is really hard to say
but let me come back to you so far in
this discussion we've spoken about this
rather messy divorce we've spoken about
the emotional impact we've spoken about
the division of assets and we've spoken
about how who the friends and neighbors
are siding with but tell me yet does
this divorce ever really happen does it
in fact ever go to court if there's
gonna be a courtroom battle the election
presidential election campaign that's
brewing up here in the United States
looks like a courtroom battle Donald
Trump's got this a whole argument that
he's not to blame for the coronavirus
Trump saying no China is to blame China
is to blame for it it covered up it lied
bald-faced lying
it's bigger than Pearl Harbor the more
American deaths and not only is China to
blame for covering it up and originating
the pathogen but it also has in Joe
Biden the Democratic nominee a big
friend of China a big friend an
apologist for China somebody wants to
normalize relations between the US and
China drug seized this anti China
completing the divorce with China as his
re-election bid so I guess my question
to you James you know in this in this
pretty troubling context of relations
between the two countries and this
election where China is going to be
front and center
it's Kanna divorce be avoided if Trump
is reelected on that basis I think it'll
be very difficult I think the advent of
a second term for Donald Trump would be
greeted in Beijing by something close to
horror the main problem with a
relationship right now is that it's very
difficult to see a natural break in the
unraveling of
these ties between the two countries
it's very difficult to see a way in
which the u.s. can reach out to China
and China can reach out to the u.s. to
put a floor under this fast
deteriorating relationship